- Money wins.
- You're corrupt and so is the world.
- You were only with me to get to power.
- Ah, their whole relationship's
just such a disaster.
My name is Douglas Boneparth.
I'm a certified financial planner.
Today I'm gonna break down the finances
of the characters in
the show "Succession."
- I was just talking to my mom.
- It's a great scene.
- And she said, apparently,
he'll leave me $5 million anyway
so I'm golden baby.
- It's actually a very bad
financial planning concept
to think that there's
going to be a windfall
in the future when you
really don't have an idea
as to when, how much,
or having any control
over that whatsoever.
- You can't do anything with five, Greg.
Five's a nightmare.
- This is the best part.
- Is it?
- Oh yeah, can't retire.
Not worth it to work.
- Now, let's say Greg
inherits $5 million today.
Generally speaking,
inheritance from family members
or anyone from that matter
is received tax free.
Well, how much can Greg live on
without running out of money?
The 3% rule is a convenient rule of thumb
because it demonstrates what
we could at least get out
of a sum of money by
investing it prudently.
So 3% of 5 million would give
Greg about $150,000 a year.
Now, that's a pretty good
living by anyone's standard
but he's sitting in his great
uncle's $63 million penthouse
on Fifth Avenue, and he
appears to be drinking a bottle
of Blanton's Single Barrel.
If this is the lifestyle that
Greg has become accustomed to,
$5 million isn't going to cut it.
- Greg, do you think we
could figure this out?
You wanna transfer now?
It's 40 K.
- Here's the thing, if that's
a stainless steel Submariner,
nowhere near $40,000.
But what about watches
being a good investment?
Yes, there are some watches
out there that do appreciate
in value over time.
Will Greg make out well
with his $40,000 investment
in this watch?
Time will tell, but you'll
probably do better investing
in the US stock market.
- If I try to say the truth.
- My favorite interaction
between the two of them, I think period.
So I love this one
- All my life,
I've been thinking a
little bit about money.
- In the scene where Tom tells Shiv
that he often thinks about money,
he's really laying out
his financial background.
We know his mother is.
- A highly respected
attorney in the Twin Cities.
- And a job like that
probably earns anywhere
from 180,000 to $250,000 a year.
Far cry from billionaire status.
(crowd chatting indistinctly)
- Well, this is delicious. Yeah, wow.
- I'm very glad you like it.
- Because it cost a pretty penny.
- This whole scene is a great
way of showing the disparity
between the backgrounds that
both Shiv and Tom come from.
If you're wondering what
the venue costs where Tom
and Shiv are getting married,
well, we looked it up.
It's about $19,000 for two days.
- It's massive.
- Logan owns this castle and therefore,
has to not only maintain
it, but upkeep it.
We see a scene in a room,
we got priceless pieces of art.
We can only begin to imagine
how much this castle actually costs.
- Come on, there's nothing
wrong with his body,
it's just suits.
- Is he wearing a suit in that scene?
- [Speaker] You look
like a divorce attorney
from the Twin Cities.
- I don't put it past Tom to
spend some money on a suit.
He says he really likes his suit.
Maybe spends $600 to
$1,000, had it tailored.
Looks good.
For most people, that's an expensive suit.
We see Tom upgrade his
career into becoming the head
of ATN where he should have
no issues affording any type
of suit that he wants,
custom, off the rack,
designer, whatever it may be.
- It's a really, really nice place.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
- Who'll get to keep it in the divorce?
(both chuckling)
- So in season four, we learn that Tom
and Shiv may get divorced.
It brings up a great question,
how are the assets going
to be divided?
So when we think about the
assets in most people's lives,
that could get split up
during divorce, it comes down
to things like their retirement
accounts, checking accounts
and the family home.
We have a feeling that they
live in lower Manhattan
in an apartment that costs
at least $5.8 million.
If Tom and Shiv do get divorced, a prenup,
which we know Tom likely
has signed, comes into play
and that will spell out exactly
what he does or does not get.
- She says that the prenup
is a little unconscionable.
- Oh, hold it.
That means it has to be so bad and so not
in Tom's favor for a
lawyer to use that term.
- But she did notice that re infidelities,
there's no clause.
- Yeah, we don't need to do that.
- It is common to see
infidelity clauses in prenups,
but whether two people
should enter into a prenup,
that's really about what's right for them.
You want to have a sense
of how they value money.
What possessions or assets that
they have are truly theirs.
- All the top attorneys
are conflicted out.
- Conflicted out means
that there's a conflict
of interest with that
attorney representing her.
Spending a lot of money
on an attorney doesn't always
guarantee good results.
But look, you usually get
what you pay for here.
I can't help but to have this feeling
that Shiv will be okay
and it's really Tom that's
going to be, you know,
working hard to figure out
what he's entitled to, if anything at all.
- I'm one of the executors
of your dad's affairs.
- In season four.,
Logan's death is the main event
that ultimately sets off the
name of the show, "Succession."
- And it appears, at a
certain point, undated.
It was suggested that it
was your dad's wish that.
- Okay
- Kendall take over as CEO.
- Okay, so classic.
There's a codicil here.
That's an amendment to a will
or a legal document.
This is actually pretty common.
- He underlined, recently.
- Underlined or crossed out?
- This only emphasizes the need
to have clear communication
with those you're putting in charge
of handling your estate.
To ensure that this doesn't happen to you,
it's probably good form to make sure
that all estate planning
documents are in one place
and if you are working on any changes,
to communicate what those
potential changes might be
so you don't catch anyone off guard,
like Logan here clearly is.
- [Lawyer] What else is in the?
Can you? I don't wanna...
- Music, burial in the city, Catholic.
- We're not just talking about assets,
the things that you own.
We're also talking about children.
And for more advanced
estate planning cases,
you have trusts or trusts
being born out of the will.
- He's got like a ton of
investment impressionisms, right?
Like he's got three Gauguins
no one's seen for tax reasons.
- And then you hear about
three Gauguin paintings
and those paintings can
fetch more than $100 million.
So what's the tax planning around this?
Likely so that those assets
are excluded from the estate,
that there would not need to
be estate tax paid on that.
Generally speaking, it's never a bad idea
to have your basic estate
planning documents in place.
This is your last will and
testament, powers of attorney,
healthcare proxy and a living will.
(tranquil music)
Here in the show, we really
do get our first glimpse
at what Kendall might actually be worth.
Most of these shares probably
have a very low basis,
meaning they were gifted a long time ago,
which means a significant portion
of that sale is going to be capital gains.
You might as well take about 1/3
of that gain off the table for the taxman.
So in this scene, we have Kendall going
to an investor meeting and
unboxing a pair of sneakers
from Lanvin, and he wants to show off
that he's got great style
walking into a meeting.
Now, I'm under the impression
that Kendall is spending his
own money to look the part.
Some could argue is he taking a deduction
to wear these clothes
because it has something to do with work.
Now, typically, that's
reserved for uniforms.
I wouldn't go quite calling a pair
of Lanvin sneakers a uniform.
However, computers, transportation, meals
and expenses, wages, these are
all very, very typical things
that get written off
as part of deductions.
(lively music)
In this scene, you get a really good look
at how the Roy family,
in this case Kendall, likes to travel.
This helicopter company
can take you from Manhattan
to the Hamptons for
about $4,000 plus taxes,
which if you are asking the question,
is that deductible?
Probably.
So when it comes to deducting expenses
for business purposes,
there's usually not a limit
on the quality of things
but there are certain
thresholds, percentage of income
or revenue that would create
what's called an audit risk.
And while Roman might
not be visibly as fancy
as his brother Kendall,
he clearly too likes to
travel in style and comfort
on his private jet costing about
$16,000 an hour to charter.
And we see Roman pull up
in two Chevy Suburbans,
which would run about $800
a day to rent in Manhattan.
Logan created this empire
and he clearly was set out
to leave this to his children
but his children are so affected
that he might not actually
get to see his own wishes
for them be carried out.
And this is all very typical in situations
where we're talking about
business enterprises
being passed down through family members.
(pensive music)